so let's summarize where we left off so
we've said for any function app in AC
zero we have two senses in which we can
approximate it by a low degree
polynomial over the real numbers the
first sense is the Fourier approximation
which is numerically very close but only
over the uniform distribution we don't
really have a good notion of Fourier
expansion over an arbitrary K wise
independent distribution and whether
that would be the same and whether the
obey is random restriction so on the
unit on uniform inputs we know this is
very good approximation but maybe all
the places that it differs are exactly
those where there are that are in the
support of the K was independent
distribution that we're trying to
compare things to so so stuck here how
we're going to use this to get from the
bridge upon the random distribution to F
on the K wise independent distribution
so our goal is to show that the
expectation of F on the random
distribution is it much larger than the
expectation on the K less independent
distribution I'm just going to prove one
inequality of course we can apply the
same reasoning to not F to get the other
inequality so this suffice is to show
that the difference isn't too large okay
so so so this is a good numerical
approximation but may not apply to one
of our two distributions the other sense
is we have a probabilistic construction
that works point by point so with the
appropriate choices of randomness we can
get it to work both on the uniform
distribution and on the K wise
independent distribution the problem is
that when it doesn't work it's really
really bad we have no control over it so
so we need to like combine these two
ways of approximating into one that
avoids applause of the both of us
so so one of oh and I should say here's
the here's the bound we had on the
degree for the first approximation from
the lineaments Ernest on paper and
here's the update from people in the
audience and then during the break here
here was the degree of the the
rosboroughs molesky like approximation
from the brahmin paper but here's the
update from people in the audience that
i found out during the break it's very
similar by harsha and Srinivasan in that
we the dependence on the on the side
stays the same and probably up to this
factor of two is tight but the the
dependence on the the approximation has
moved over is just linear
so or just one logarithmic okay so I'm
not sure whether this this one is going
to be improved things fairly
dramatically
I haven't goop I just found this out
newsflash
so I haven't really incorporated this
into calculations so any questions about
where we were so um
real clever idea from bravura men's
paper is that we can tell it's actually
fairly simple the complexity of saying
when we might have made a mistake in
this second approximation because we
have this criteria for for what we're
you know what we're doing the Union
bound over it's all sources of possible
error so what what could go wrong is
we'd have some gate key that's an or
gate that's actually true but when we do
the approximation we get something we
don't get the right value in other words
every set subset of the inputs that we
picked doesn't intersect the the ones in
the input in exactly one place now you
can just write down there are either 0
inputs or 2 inputs that are that are one
two distinct inputs both of those are AC
0 type formulas you can do this or
overall gates in AC 0 both of these like
add depth 1 to the formula and multiply
the formula by some polynomial well put
the size by a polynomial so we end up
with a formula for for this error
function sort of watch function Guardian
function that has size polynomial in s
and the parameter T so basically s since
T was like poly log and in depth
just a constant more than what we
started with so um so in fact we're not
actually going to apply the Fourier
approximation to the original function
we're gonna apply it to this error
function this partying function so so
when you look in terms of this Guardian
function then you have like the place
where the Guardian is true okay the you
know look at where F capital F is zero
then goes over to F equals 1 we're just
lining them up to make them contiguous
then the place where e could be true
little F follows the curve except for
this interval where little F can be
almost it can be like huge or hugely
negative and then it goes back and
follows the curve again so we want to
approximate F by the well-behaved part
of F so I'm going to call that L is not
e where the error doesn't happen and F
is true and I'm going to write L in a
really kind of bizarre way it's
logically equivalent but it's not clear
why I'm doing this except that it's
going to be a good way once I've done
that I'm going to like replace certain
functions by their approximations and
then it'll sort of make sense
so thing okay not E&F is the same as 1
minus e times f e is boolean so e
squared is Z so I can write this as 1
minus e squared what's the advantage of
doing that well no real difference if B
is boolean but when I replace it with a
real valued function now I'm
guaranteeing that this quantity is is
bounded by 1 so similarly I'm gonna
write F as not not F 1 minus 1 minus F
but then I'm gonna square the 1 minus F
1 minus F is also boolean so squaring
doesn't matter but but again this when I
replace this with a real approximation
I'm going to you to be cure that I'm
less than 1 so here I claim that I can
actually apply the real approximation
here why is that well either a is 0 in
which case there's no difference between
these two or e is 1 in which case
whatever I've written here is about
irrelevant because I'm multiplying by 0
okay so now I'll compare that to so now
- so this is just this function
I haven't actually changed it I've just
written it in a kind of bizarre way and
now I'm going to like make a real-valued
function that's in some sense an
approximation and I've already replaced
F by its approximation little app and
what I'm going to do is replace ie by
its Fourier approximation each ILDA
so um a few facts about about L and L
tilde and how they relate to the
original function remember that L is
between f minus is just a pet naughty
so it's bigger than f minus E and it's
the most F on a little more subtle claim
that L tilde is at most F plus e why is
that true again we'll have a like a case
analysis either equals zero there's no
error and F equals big f which means L
tilde is some function and that you know
something quantity that's less than 1
times F this what this not not it
becomes f again and that's always less
than wrinkled-ass so otherwise equals 1
and you note that we've set up L tilde
to be certainly less than 1
[Music]
right fine know this I know
negative yeah but the second term is
never left this boolean right no it's
not yeah
okay so
yeah
so I'm gonna just change it and add plus
e squared minus e to the squared
this one so now hopefully hopefully I
got this right so so like it equals 1
then this is Jeff Stowell tilde and this
is adding something positive
okay so this isn't how I brought hope
how Michael did it but let's see if it
works Mikey's not negative right come in
it could be negative that's the problem
but then how do we get an equality equal
to 0 case o if P equals 0 then F equals
capital app ok
okay and oh you've good to one month
you've got an epsilon squared F that you
can play with that you didn't use before
there was a one minus Epsilon till it
sorry II told two squared
yeah that is you know on the right hand
side if you look at the case one second
line yeah you have on the right hand or
in the green you have this minus e tilde
squared F that you didn't use before but
now that will cancel the ITO the this
will be that will cancel the negative
each other oh yeah maybe
did I do it the wrong way
now you're getting an exactly what about
if I put in absolute value here actually
yeah
I'll put an absolute value there and
then that should be fine whenever F
capital F people zero okay so I was
always also that yeah whenever whenever
capital F equals zero but I wanted this
to be less than or equal to one if this
was if they both of these are if F is
one but both of these are very negative
that I could be in trouble
so bottom so if if equals
one
equals zero this is this is true and
this is positive
if
he is one then this is this term is just
the absolute value of this so it's found
it slower validated by its absolute
value
I'm improvising I hope this works
so let's see okay this wasn't this ugly
part was not in Mark's paper
okay
okay so then
so
we want to look at up on the random
distribution
because L is just F when e doesn't
happen this is a most L on the random
distribution
Plus e on the random distribution
okay
so then we can just like add and
subtract
don't tilde
and what l - l tilde okay
if this was an e versus this with an e
tilde so if we like so crack up we get
something this we get an upper bound of
this absolute value
which is why I thought it was safe to
and the second part is like 2 F plus F
squared
actually
- EPS squared but don't take absolute
values
I'm the random yes vacation of that on
the random on the uniform distribution
book plus now L tilde on the random
distribution is the same as L tilde
I'm sorry I can't do this because this
is going to end up on the unlock a wise
it's the same form as the error term I
already had but now it's going to be on
the K wise independent distribution
oh let me give another go at it sorry
okay
let's see if this works okay so
so I guess did the negated negated trick
earlier so we get one - so this is the
negation of this squared doesn't change
yet vacation and again when I replace
the capital F by little app if E is one
the B is zero there's no difference if E
is one there's no difference because
this is zero so okay now if I replace
the any bias approximation now since I'm
just having one term which is of the
form 1 minus something squared this is
definitely less than or equal to 1 so so
so L tilde is so if equals zero kappa
little little F equals capital F and
this is L tilde he is just ask
it's the negation of the negation of
little of little F which is the negation
negation of capital F equals 1 then this
disappears eat it equals 1 then then L
tilde is less than equal to 1 is less
than you'll to have plus C because I now
have it of the form 1 minus something
squared instead of the product of two
things like that and so there can't be
anything wrong it if you just subtract
them Square from 1 you never get more
than one but four zeroes an ld50 well
you know it's a it equals zero little F
equals capital F yeah okay and equals
zero oh oh oh I see so this is saying
this is capital F zero and easier than
30 okay in fact APF equals zero then
yeah then this equals zero otherwise we
just use it I'll tilde is less than
Eagle one which is the most
okay
now let's try this argument
so I can see at least one sorry hope
because you we're assuming that it's not
true that Ian and F are both zero so it
since they're bullying one of them is at
least one okay and this is true over any
kind of input so particularly over both
distributions an app
okay
so so we can so now let's look at what
happens to L minus L tilde well both are
1 minus something squared so the
difference the ones cancel is the
difference between these squares is
going to be the sum and the difference
so
so they get
so we get something that some it's going
to be something like order B plus C
tilde
Plus sorry
the difference is going to be the
difference f times the difference
between these two
so I get just this some times the
absolute value of that times the
difference is going to be like on the
order of app times the difference
between these plus L tilde a brand
you also erased but there's an e of ram
that you drop first on that second line
yeah
you erased like a I ran after the plus
unless I hit like the last plus o plus
yeah around the plus the event okay
look here and is this Delta so we have
like Delta plus the expectation two plus
E Plus E tilde times F squared times e -
e tilde
plus the expectation of L tilde on rent
this we can again like write as put a
plus at E and put an e - E tilde so when
we break it up the absolute value here
is bounded by four times the F squared
times e e- the expectation of the
absolute value of B - E tilde so this is
that like most four times the maximum
value of F squared times the expected
value of e - E tilde and then the other
term P - E tilde times e - E tilde we
have an F squared times that expectation
so this is going to be Delta plus M
square plus order M squared times square
root of epsilon because remember that
the that we had the difference between
the value of E and this expectation is
the most and absolute values the most up
epsilon and as its square root of
epsilon and the sorry
M is the maximum value of F so I should
have
okay
so and then plus L Hilda right
so these things are kind of under
control
well tilde Rand here's where we use that
K wise independence exactly preserves
the the the the value of low degree
polynomials L tilde is a is a polynomial
of degree roughly the degree of E Plus
the degree of F square double so as long
as we make a large enough compared to
those two
[Music]
okay and what do we know about L tilde
we know L tilde is a most F plus e over
any distribution
so this is a most Delta plus order M
squared square root of e plus f of K and
plus e of K end
and we also know AFK end only happens
with probability Delta
so now we know that the function up the
function on the random distribution
isn't far off from the function on the
cable is independent so
okay
so the one thing now is to like
calculate how big K has to be so
the main thing here is you know we want
this to be about our final gamma over
some constant so Delta can be like order
the gamma that we want at the end but
epsilon has to be has to be like gamma
times and
is a negative gamma squared times m to
the negative 4m was asked to the d2
so
in d2 they were you know picking Delta
to be about gamma D to was lawcast over
Delta to the to the order T so so if we
were using the the original bound as as
bra vermin did then so epsilon has to be
something like f to the negative you
know s to the
expert exponential in s to the
sorry just to the it's gonna be
exponential in law gas to the order
which means that the d1 is going to have
this log of s over epsilon that's going
to be forget the s but the log of the
one over epsilon is going to be like log
s to the D and so a d1 is going to be
log s to the order d squared
this one is our Kayla so deep okay
our K is going to be d 1 times D 2
double it's going to be 2 d 1 d 2
because we multiply them in then square
but the most of the d 1 is going to be
the most significant factor
so so our K is going to be order D 1 D 2
wishes
mrs. palsey
yes justice um ok so then but times -
yeah so the D one's gonna become pretty
much irrelevant even we multiplied them
the D one would be pretty much
irrelevant this one is going to be
pretty significant okay
because we need to pick epsilon much
smaller than this one in M and we need
to pick an M is growing proportionally
duty to you know exponentially with D -
so this one is going to D 1 is going to
be the one
did I say T - I think I did yeah so D 1
is gonna dominate and be logged as to
the order T squared okay but what
happens if we do this instead then even
though epsilon has to be really small it
doesn't get raised to another D so if we
use a of a science improvement it's the
same argument but then our final K is
going to be log s see the water D
and maybe if we use this in addition we
could get a further improvement by I
don't know exactly what
okay so I think the main part that I did
really care really quickly because this
was was like shelling was like hand
waving was going through this should I
go through that more more detail or just
keep on going just declare victory what
was the peak placement that has happened
and yet then you introduce this e and
then a bunch of inequalities but what is
it that we cared about our process okay
so what I try to like back up and say
okay so so there were those two
complications so we had these two kinds
of approximate approximation one and we
want to go from one to the other so once
we move from so once we convert
everything to a low degree polynomial
remove the boolean functions and replace
them by low degree polynomials we can
move from the uniform distribution to
the pseudorandom to the K wise
independent distribution but once we do
that we can't we cannot claim any kind
of numerical closeness of these
approximating functions with the
original so we have to be pretty sure
that there's some kind of way of
bounding them that works input by input
globally once we move into the once we
move into the pseudo-random distribution
so yeah so like so here we want it to be
so here in this approximation which
wasn't true before we know okay when
things are working well when
on the right hand side is that what we
care about
sorry so which which being between F and
s with Epsilon yeah so so we because we
want to because we want to upper bound
you know we're just shooting saying that
the the value on the rent uniform
distribution isn't much bigger than the
value on the K wise independent
distribution we don't care if this
function becomes like hugely negative on
the K wise independent distribution well
we care about as if it like suddenly
became hugely positive and by writing it
as 1 minus a square we're sure that
whatever happens it doesn't become
usually positive
loading people love it which is like
never to which is and then it's never
too much higher than that and usually
it's lower because he only happens
fairly rarely even on the even on the
pseudo random distribution
okay
so okay
so maybe I'll just say like I have ten
minutes left I have 10 minutes left
before so why are you know
now I'll begin the second half of my
talk so okay so what let's see let's
write it like saying well we we did here
here we like took a lower bound proof
and we used it to show that to give like
a positive characterization of what we
could compute in the class and then use
that to show what kind of distributions
full full the the other approach is to
try to take a generic hard problem and
use that to construct a distribution
so let me just say what was known and
give like one open problem that pretty
much everyone already knows but we
should be working on anyway
so the other half of the talk would talk
about the nasaan Winterson construction
where you take a heart you have a
function that is hard for some circuit
model C and it's come generic in that
for every small C
the probability the C of x equals f of X
is it Mos Eisley is the most I happen so
you have this very hard on average
problem and you use that to directly
compute a discipline a distribution in
the idea is that f of X looks like one
bit of randomness given up
and so what we'll do what we try to do
is extend this to we could say like oh
well given x1 through XK F of x1 through
F of XK look like K bits of randomness
unfortunately the ratio between how many
bits were using and how many bits we get
out you know here we got we use we could
like say X is random X F X f of X looks
like an additional ran a bit the ratio
hasn't changed and cade random bits give
us n k plus k so this is true so what
they do instead is show how to construct
from a single relatively small random
string a sequence of X eyes that are not
independent because they're all
generated in the same way but look quite
a computationally independent in that
knowing f of X I doesn't help you much
with figuring out what F of XK is in
fact knowing any information about X I
doesn't really tell you much about X
about any function on X J so that's a
very clever construction the one and the
son used this to show a different can
you know be pre pre bra Vermin
construction of pseudo-random generator
AC zero because we know the parity
function is such a hard function
but this works this this hypothetical
construction works for pretty much any
circuit family yeah for any circuit
class and if we have a large enough
complexity class then in fact we can
replace replace the hard on average with
a worst-case hardness y so you think of
a the truth table for a worst-case heart
function as a message and we want to
construct a hard on average problem so
what that means is we're constructing
some other problems a capital F so that
if we can even compute capital F with
some epsilon advantage then we can
compute it little F so what that amounts
to is a kind of error correcting code
saying what will you think of capital F
as the code of little F and then give an
even a very highly corrupted code word
we should be able to recover a little F
so what we want in terms of coding is we
want a list decodable
it's because we're the and the size of
the list is going to correspond to the
non uniformity in the construction of
the circuit of F from the circuit
reduce not in law but this is really his
idea his way of looking at well that
would be nice
there's a big problem though okay yes
the decoder has to be local difference
so it'd be nice if also the encoder were
local there's a problem though in that
no local encoder can have a good
distance you can split it though into
two parts
so if you split it into two parts
there's a part where you have to you go
from a worst-case heart function to a
somewhat heart function
and that part can't be local so this
part is just sort of like a constant
distant error correcting code or even
like a Polliwog distance error
correcting rate error correcting code
but then from afar you can think of the
XOR lemma or other versions of hardness
amplifying as giving you what I'll call
an approximately local listing codable
where the code is so I guess a locally
computable in approximately local list
eco double code so let me exact same
other words are the locally computable
means that we can compute app any one
bit of F using a black box for a bit of
f bar local list decodable means that we
can compute that bar using an Oracle for
a for some version sorry it reverse that
hey you can compute any one bit of F
using an Oracle where far we can compute
F bar using an Oracle for F list means
that actually will need some advice to
distinguish because there you know there
won't be a unique F bar for that F so
we'll need some advice or have a list of
possible candidates and approximate
means actually we won't really be
computing F will be computing just some
function that's relatively close to F so
I'm close enough that if we compose it
with a decode the decoder here we would
actually reconstruct the French so so
using this machinery you can say
generically we can take even worst-case
hardness assumptions and use them to
Deere analyze algorithms
and I guess like the the strongest
one of the strongest results along these
lines if there exists a function in E
where the size of that is not into to
the little ol event
so so presumably we could use a
strong-enough circuit lower bound 2d
randomized pretty much any algorithm
so so the the the open problem is so we
know this generic construction between
hardness and randomness D randomization
and we successfully applied it to
exactly one complexity class it ACCAC
zero so why don't we apply it to another
complexity class and the challenge is
the class has to be the limited enough
that we actually have a lower bound
unconditionally but strong enough that
okay either we have to get the lower
bound for this very hard on average
condition that where we can apply the
nasaan Winterson construction directly
or we need to get a lower bound for a
class that's strong enough that we can
do this kind of error correcting and
right now there is no class where we
have both so the main open problem is to
take some class like AC with mod gates a
c0 with mod gates and actually give a
good pseudo-random generator for that
class the best way would be by proving a
strong average case lower bound but I
would be happy for any other way
[Music]
[Applause]